you
and are extremely aggressive animals yet
some species such as honeypot ants seen
here staged ritual fights in which a
hostile message is communicated but only
rarely are participants
injured or killed when two ends meet
they immediately sized one other up
approaching head-on and making
themselves appear larger with this place
such as stiffening their legs sticking
their abdomens high into the air and
climbing on to higher ground for up to
30 seconds they kick and feel one
another with their legs and antennae
before disengaging uninjured
and moving on to the next end
just the single foreign and can bring on
a display but such face offs grow in
number as scouting hands recruit workers
from their respective colonies during
these tournaments Kouts constantly
evaluate the sizes of the two groups the
determining which is stronger when the
opponents in a mock battle become uneven
Sailaja team may move in to overtake the
smaller groups nest if it retreats
quickly enough the smaller team can
close off the nest and hide out until
its opponent or tires only when the
retreat isn't fast enough peaceful
tensions unfold into genuine violence
and the larger team rates a smaller list
carrying off the young killing or
running off the Queen and stealing honey
pots
and on the only animals to display shows
of force in groups for example birds
known as Greenwood who boosts utilize
calling contests to settle disputes and
some human cultures engaged in so-called
nothing fights in which armed warriors
gestured and shouted but rarely come
into physical contact from an
evolutionary perspective non fights
benefit both opponents since in real
fights even the victors risk injury and
the fact that organisms from across taxa
engaged in similar displays demonstrates
that such behaviors can emerge without
organized leaders or higher intelligence
you